on average hotel prices have largely
rebounded from 2020 lows and are now on
par with pre-pandemic rates but there
are huge differences from city to city
especially when comparing rates in
vacation towns like ours and those that
rely heavily on business
travelers in major vacation towns like
miami
las vegas
orlando prices are back to where they
were pandemic or even above in miami
they're 20 above where they were
pre-pandemic willis orlando of scott's
cheap flights tracks everything from
airfare to hotel rates and rental car
rates he says according to str a global
hospitality data and analytics company
hotels are less full across the country
than they were in 2019 leading in some
markets to cheaper rates among the
current best value destinations are
these big cities that rely heavily on
business travel
new york where i'm from washington dc
san francisco prices are still very low
so if you're planning a city break in
one of these places you're in really
good shape you know in san francisco
right now the average hotel rate is 40
percent lower than it was in 2019.
chicago minneapolis and seattle are also
seeing hotel rates about 10 percent
cheaper analysts expect this to be the
trend going forward for now prices in
the vacation markets like ours will
probably come back down a little bit but
orlando says it all really depends on
the business traveler what happens in
the other markets